off-camera Blaine you were talking about
ideas being in the ether the zeitgeist
about writing something that someone
else is already writing and you don't
even know they don't even know if I
sorry I just think everything every idea
has a moment right like we're all
watching the same stuff we're all we're
all on Facebook we're seeing the same
news articles the same sensory input is
coming across our you know our brains
and like you take a couple of steps as a
screenwriter you're always trying to
find a hook find a new idea find
something and I think there's just I
think it's indefinable I really do but
like ideas have a moment so I like this
my story is that I had come up with this
this script which was a supernatural
thriller kind of thing and it was a
jumping off from The Da Vinci Code which
was very successful at the at the moment
and so I had this you know idea about
like this clone of Christ idea that was
that was the big hook and it's a really
good script actually still is anyways
with like this little action mystery
thing so agent flipped out
loved it fantastic as a long time ago
when we printed scripts so I'd print it
out you know 52 scripts and we had to
pay for that I don't know if you're
aware but in the smaller agencies I had
to go and print 50 scripts so anyways
feel bad for me so I printed these 50
scripts I taken my agent I drop him off
and then I go to work at this bar and I
walk into the bar and the bartender who
I work with has a Hollywood Reporter on
the bar and I'm like what's this he's
like I got hired to write a script today
for this big production company big
secret idea secret script so I got hired
for it fantastic you're out of the bar
business congratulations you know and I
look at the article and I think the
title is interesting and it sounds a lot
like what would be the title of my movie
and I'm like what's your movie about
it's like I this clone of Christ thing
and I didn't tell him the idea the idea
wasn't even his he was hired to do that
job but the same day I'm telling you
like the day that I printed this stuff
out to go around town was two days after
he closed the deal and
came out in The Hollywood Reporter and I
think it's like that all the time you
know you have these competing movies
that are happening at the same time we
need two movies about volcanoes that's a
long time ago two movies about again
fake but you know there's lots of movies
like that and people racing to the
finish line because ideas have these
moments and they're not stolen of each
other they're each of us going our own
way with the sensory input that's
available and we end up with the same
conclusion so the moral is then if
you're going to write something do it
now
yep it's you're sorry and get out there
the moral is you better hurry that's
because he never you never talk to him
about no no never did and like you know
it wasn't even his idea he applied to
get this writing position that was like
an open writing position like he was top
secret but but like that's my agents
thought he thought that I had told this
guy and I'm over this guy just went in
for a meeting and they said you know put
together a pitch for this and he did and
he got the job I could have gotten the
job probably with my script had things
worked out differently do you know any
mean right but I don't know I just I
think it's funny the coincidence and
it's not really coincidence it's like if
I tell a thousand people the same facts
you know somebody is going to come up
with the same idea that I have right in
also to world event
yes exactly shaping our mindset and and
what we're kind of gearing towards right
wow that's really interesting yeah and
so once you knew that when you went home
that night what was your whole I mean
that was honestly like I've had you know
some crushing disappointments that was
probably in the top three it was bad
because you know like you spend so much
time on a script and then like you give
it to an agent the agent would be like
ah you have any westerns you know I mean
that's normally what happens is like
you're like I have this script is hot
and they'll read it and be like you know
there's a movie that just sold a couple
of weeks ago that's kind of this kind of
tone what else you got like well I just
spent you know nine months making this
for you so like it's incredibly
disappointing to put work into something
and then have it
a response like my the biggest criticism
I you normally got into my agents is
that my scripts are not high-concept
enough like I like small stories I like
stories with like four or five people
you know and all of my movies that I've
made have really been about three people
and you know there are ancillary
characters of course but like it's a
small little world that's interesting to
me like I my instinct is not to go and
write Independence Day you know where
you have you know a general having this
in of reporters over here and you know
then you have characters on the other
side of the world that's not my thing
so when an agent sees money signs when
they look at one of my scripts that's a
rarity and something that I'm like oh
great fantastic you're happy I'm happy
let's you know go sell it and then for
the rug to be pulled out from under
without the script even getting a shot
that was hard I went to the bathroom I
got sick I freaked out on my manager
basically saying what am I gonna do you
know and he's like what do you mean what
you're gonna do you're gonna go home and
you're gonna start writing something
else I took a couple of days though I
had the wine the next time that I did
right right and the candles you have a
candle yeah is an incense you know a
calming kind of real a stage clearing
yeah exactly I need to clean this that's
awesome
you